Sanremo non lo guardo ma per carità Chi
è che sta sveglio tutta la notte per
vedere il festival e il pres Sanremo e
il Sanremo e il dopo Sanremo Ma poi
Fossero almeno delle belle canzoni ma
sono una più brutta dell'altra dei
cantanti in gara quest'anno Sai quanti
ne conosco tre ti ho detto tutto ai miei
tempi che andava a Sanremo sapeva
cantare proprio le basi No questi si
mettono gli effetti che ti intonano e
Beh anche io posso io il prossimo anno
vado a Sanremo anche io ma poi questi
monologhi Io voglio guardare Sanremo per
la musica non me ne frega niente di
sentire sti monologhi di merda Una volta
la protagonista Infatti era la musica
adesso si parla solo dei vestiti che
indossano e i social e tutte queste cose
qui la musica non gliene frega niente a
nessuno guarda io mi rifiuto di come è
successo adesso io non lo voglio seguire
vengo qua dal parrucchiere e Sanremo
Sanremo non ne voglio sentir parlare
Saro Adesso io mi chiudo in casa tutta
la settimana va bene